[Applause]
that was awesome good morning good
morning and welcome to Ellington Field
at NASA's Johnson Space Center in
Houston I'm Joe acaba thank you
I'm Joe acaba chief of NASA's astronaut
office and I'm joined by Norm Knight
director of NASA's flight operations
directorate
we are here today with the mission to
introduce the world to the crew of
Artemis 2. four names four explorers
four of my friends answering the call to
once more rocket away from Earth and
chart a course around the Moon
well Joe I
I
agree with you Joe but we're going to
need a few more astronauts I think to
get this started so everyone please help
me welcome our astronaut core
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
look at that sea of blue let's give them
another round of applause
our mission calls for four names
it's difficult to pick just four from a
group that by its very definition
attracts the best and the brightest that
Humanity has to offer
the astronaut core our entire astronaut
core will be the forerunners as Humanity
looks to find its place Among the Stars
so that while we may be recognizing four
individuals today
I want to thank the entire astronaut
Corps for their dedication and sacrifice
as we ask them to strap into our current
and future spacecraft
take those next steps to do the things
that are hard so that others might
follow behind them
now
now some of you might be scanning the
astronaut faces trying to see who is
missing and still hidden backstage
well know this your Artemis 2 crew
members are already here in the room
with you
but
because I love you all I'm going to give
you one hint I am not one of them
don't be so happy about that
with Artemis one we set out to prove
that the hardware was ready that SLS was
prepared to launch our astronauts
Skyward
that Orion was equipped to carry them to
the moon and back safely again
Artemis 1 was a resounding success and
Artemis 2 will leverage that by putting
humans in the loop executing operations
in the critical path leading to new
footprints on the lunar surface
foreign
[Music]
this flight will be challenging but we
faced that challenge with the confidence
that the people working beside us are up
to the task
Houston is home for us and it's where
we'll plan train and ultimately fly the
Artemis II mission to give us a proper
Houston welcome please join me in
bringing out JSC Center Director Vanessa
White
thank you Joe
good morning I'd like to welcome
everyone here today to Ellington Field
NASA's Johnson Space Center is home of
America's astronaut Corps Mission
operations and foundational human space
flight programs this past December we
witnessed history as the Orion capsule
journeyed on a 1.4 million mile Journey
around the Moon and back and the
excitement Contin
as we prepare for Artemis 2 for the
first time with crew
we've made many giant leaps in the past
60 years fulfilling President Kennedy's
goal of Landing a person on the moon and
today we stand on the shoulders of
giants as we reach farther into the
stars and push forward to the Moon once
again and on to Mars these individuals
of Artemis 2 crew will be the first
humans to fly to the vicinity of the
Moon in more than 50 years
yes
I'd like to take a moment to recognize
those who paved the way our Apollo
Legends who are with us via the NASA
alumni League will you please wave
we are also honored to be joined by some
special guests please help me welcome
NASA leadership administrator Bill
Nelson Deputy Administrator Pam melroy
associate administrator Bob Cabana and
many of our NASA leaders who are from
headquarters and all across our agency
we're also pleased to be joined by the
International Community
representing the Canadian space agency
is Minister champagne
[Music]
through our International Partnerships
under Artemis we're building a Global
Alliance that explores deep space for
the benefit of all I'd also like to
welcome the following elected officials
Senator Ted Cruz
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee
Congressman Brian Babin congresswoman
Lizzy Fletcher the Comptroller of Texas
Glenn Hager the mayor Pro tem of Houston
Dave Martin and many other elected
officials thank you
[Applause]
tip of your continued support last but
certainly not least I'd like to give a
shout out to the NASA Workforce and all
of those across the agency who came
together to make this a very exciting
moment and this moment in history happen
so thank you to our Workforce
joining us
joining us today are directors of our
NASA centers will you please stand
so my colleagues
this Mission represents the culmination
of years of hard work and dedication by
NASA and its partners
this is an exciting time for those
working on the International Space
Station commercial crew commercial Leo
destinations as we continue using those
platforms and conduct deep space
exploration with the Orion Gateway human
Landing system and Eva programs together
our team of civil servants and
contractors are enabling the success of
the Artemis program and this is only the
beginning for the students with us today
from Houston and Clear Creek independent
school districts and those watching you
are the future explorers the future
scientists engineers inventors and
mathematicians of the Artemis generation
thank you
under Artemis we will explore the
frontiers of space and push the
boundaries of what's possible
may walk on the moon or be one of the
many explorers who Venture onward to
Mars we're all looking forward to you
being a part of our mission and I can't
wait for you and everyone to meet our
Artemis to crew thank you
the Artemis program is Guided by Decades
of experience from sending humans to
outer space
we're building new rockets new
spacecraft new communication systems and
new ways to operate in deep space
but it isn't the technology that is
changing we've also learned that in
order to go farther we have to go
together
please join me in welcoming Minister
Francois Felipe champagne he's with us
here from Canada one of our steadfast
Partners in human space flight ready to
send one of their own to the Moon
thank you very much
well thank you Joe and uh good morning
everyone bonjour Tolman Revelations
what an honor to be here today to
represent Canada on this historic day
in his recent visit to Ottawa President
Biden said this Canada and the U.S can
do big things because we do them
together
and indeed
indeed 50 years after the end of the
Apollo missions we are going back to the
Moon
[Applause]
think about that for a moment the Moon
as Minister responsible for the Canadian
space agency I know Canadians could not
be more proud proud to have for the
first time a Canadian astronaut who will
travel to deep space as part of the
Artemis 2 mission
from
that we contributing to the future of
the lunar Gateway with the unique
Canadian Innovation Canada armed tree
France that Canada will design build and
operate a lunar utility vehicle to
support operations on the lunar space
and proud of the 60-year class of
collaboration between NASA and the
Canadian space agency a partnership
which is fueled by bold initiatives and
scientific excellence and most
importantly Canadians could not be more
proud to share this moment with our
American partners and friends which are
here today in Houston
we will not be here today without the
friendship and close partnership between
our two Nations
because this is more than just about
going back to the Moon
this is about investing in the future
this is about possibilities this is
about seizing the opportunities of the
space economy from Health to food
security to climate change and much more
so as we Embark together on this new
space era let's say is the moment let's
be ambitious and together let's Inspire
the young people watching us to reach
for the stars and become the next
generation of scientists engineers and
Explorer Mexico mountain thank you thank
you everyone
foreign
he pumped me up that was nice
next up is a group of people who need
little introduction
our agency leaders who know firsthand
what it takes to fly in space please
join me in welcoming NASA administrator
Bill Nelson
Deputy Administrator Pam melroy an
associate administrator Bob Cabana
thank you
hey everybody
members of the NASA family and the
Canadian space agency
my colleagues and my former colleagues
members of Congress
members of the Artemis generation
we are going
Pam Bob and I operate as a team as a
crew
and we are here today to introduce you
to the crew that will launch next year
2024.
to another Celestial body
the largest most powerful rocket in the
world is going to propel them onward and
upward into the heavens
and they fly to the moon
this is artemis's
[Music]
Artemis 2 mission
it's a mission that is significant in
many ways
it's a demonstration of our ability to
push the boundaries of human achievement
it's a testament to the under wavering
Passion of the team that will make it
possible
and it's a message to the world
we choose to go back to the moon and
then on to Mars
and we're going to do it together
because in the 21st century NASA
explores the cosmos with International
partners
we will unlock new knowledge and
understanding
we've always dreamed about what more is
ahead
why
because it's in our DNA it's part of us
it's who we are as adventurers as
explorers as Frontiers people
and throughout history humankind has
gazed up
at this Celestial body the moon with
Wonder
the Space Program propelled
the moon to the Forefront of culture and
consciousness
it galvanized a historic effort that we
are now the stewards of
the Moon is a symbol
of our can-do spirit
and over the course of the Artemis
missions the first woman and the first
person of color
will take giant leaps on the lunar
surface
it's been more than a half century since
astronauts journeyed to the Moon
well folks that's about to change
the mission to the moon will launch four
pioneers
but it will carry more than astronauts
Artemis 2 will carry the hopes of
millions of people around the world it
will carry the aspirations of the NASA
family who glance up at the Moon every
night knowing their efforts
will return us to the Moon
and it will carry the dreams of students
who burn the Midnight Oil in libraries
and Laboratories
preparing one day to support an autumnus
mission
and it'll carry the inspiration of the
children
who imagined themselves soaring in the
skies
we will show what is possible
when we dare to reach distant Cosmic
Shores
the crew was selected by the director of
flight operations Norm night and the
chief astronaut Joe acaba and under the
supervision of the Johnson Space Center
Director Vanessa Weiss
will you all please join us up here
and I want to acknowledge again our
Canadian Partners Minister champagne
Francois Philippe will you please come
up please
God
the Artemis II crew represents thousands
of people working tirelessly to bring us
to the Stars
this is their crew
this is our crew
this is Humanity's crew
may I introduce them to you all
[Applause]
she's an engineer who got her start at
Goddard and is no stranger to Breaking
records logging the longest continuous
space flight ever by a woman your
mission specialist Christina hammock
Coke
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
he is a master of science in physics and
F-18 pilot and a Canadian astronaut your
mission specialist Jeremy Hansen
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a Naval aviator and test pilot
that's flown over 40 different aircraft
most recently the first operational
commercial crew mission your Artemis 2
pilot Victor Glover
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
Naval aviator test pilot and leader of
the highest character
your Artemis 2 Commander Reed Wiseman
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen your Artemis 2 crew
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you administrator Nelson
and the hard part's over now right all
right good
will read Victor Christina and Jeremy I
am so proud to have you for standing
here in this moment
you are the right crew for this Mission
you are the future of Artemis and it
looks bright with you at the controls
as head of flight operations I have the
privilege of getting to know each and
every astronaut
the best part of my job the best part of
my job is that I'm surrounded by people
who Inspire who give hope to those that
might follow in their footsteps
Christina
with a work ethic and willingness to
lend a hand that only someone who spent
their Summers working on a farm growing
up can have
your Relentless Drive is unmatched you
have already made your mark in the
remote corners of our planet you have
already
been in the history books as a
record-setting astronaut
you're a Trailblazer and a role model
for every generation to come you've
already been advocating and uplifting
children in your community and I know
that you are just getting started
and
as the only professional engineer in the
crew
[Laughter]
I know who Mission Control will be
calling on when it's time to fix
something on board so we appreciate you
Victor
you wanted to be a hundred different
things when you grew up
but I can say I'm truly thankful you
ended up as a Navy pilot and an
astronaut
like so many seeing other astronauts
take flight planted the seed and when
you heard Pam melroy speak at a test
pilot conference that was the moment you
decided to apply so Pam thank you for
inspiring others
Victor you were the first person in your
family to graduate from college and you
always talk about how much of the love
and support of those around you made
your dreams possible
I can honestly say I've never met anyone
as determined as you are to spread that
same love and support until everyone who
passes into your orbit is better for it
you overcame every obstacle that came
your way
every obstacle and then you dedicated
your life to crushing those obstacles so
that future Generations can dream in a
space unbounded so thanks Victor
and finally read
and explore from the beginning
The Forest of your youth might be
smaller
than the frontier that you're heading
for now but this was always you
it's what you were meant to be
you said for a time you wanted to be a
train engineer
but I don't think trades go quiet as
fast as you need them to so
I wish the Reed of your youth the ones
that you know that you're dealing with
bullies dealing with the uncertainties
of growing up
could meet you now meet the Reed who
took his first jet for a spin and knew
he was meant to soar across the skies
the Reed who found a home and family in
the Navy and here at NASA
the Reed who led our astronauts into a
new era of space exploration and the
Reed who will lead Artemis 2 from the
earth to the moon and safely back home
again
thank you
all of you will lead us into this Brave
New Frontier
you are the Artemis generation we are
the Artemis generation
and with that I will hand it back over
to our neighbors to the north to talk
about Jeremy who will take his own place
in history
I'm going to talk about your early life
or your lovely family
I'm not gonna talk about your military
service and everything you did as a
fighter pilot an F-18 fighter pilot I'm
not even gonna talk about
it as an astronaut and being the first
Canadian to go on a lunar Mission I want
to talk about your humanity and share
with the world a story when I was with
you at the Kennedy Space Center and I
saw the power of the blue suit where we
had hundreds of people storming to
Jeremy but Jeremy did one thing he
talked to each and every one you took
the time to talk to all the school
children who were there the Artemis
generation and they are here today and
watching us you took the time to inspire
them
give them the time to thank all the
teachers who are there to support our
kids and and teach them stem skills that
will bring them in Exploration and being
the future astronauts you took the time
to talk to each and every family that
were coming from around the world and
across North America what I want to
celebrate to you is your Humanity the
fact that you have been inspiring not
only us today but keep inspiring
Humanity to you Jeremy go Canada thank
you everyone
foreign
so here we have it
read Victor Christina and Jeremy
each of these adventurers has their own
story
but together
they represent our Creed
e pluribus unum
out of many one
this is the power of space
this is the power of our space program
it unites people it brings them together
it brings parties together
to explore
to discover
to dream
together we will Usher in a new era of
exploration for a new generation of star
Sailors and dreamers
the Artemis generation
together we are going
to the Moon
to Mars
and Beyond
all right let's give a big hand to our
leadership
all right
you've heard from us so now it's time to
hear from your crew I'm going to clear
the stage and I'm going to turn things
over to our Artemis 2 Commander Reed
Wiseman
all right so I gotta ask the school kids
is it hot in here today
woo
all right and I don't think that in my
14 years at Nasa we've had this many
astronauts in one place at one time I'm
losing my voice we're having so much fun
backstage it is great to see this
diverse International Group awesome to
be here with you guys
uh I'm gonna hand it over to uh the
gentleman to my right here uh Victor
Glover who has become in the last few
years an amazing mentor to me I didn't
ask for it he didn't ask for it it just
happened that way uh one of the the best
leaders I know one of the best dads
husbands and friends and uh and one of
the most talented aviators I've ever met
Victor Glover
thank you
I appreciate that wow what a day look at
all of this this is amazing isn't it I
mean after all of that I feel like
Denzel Washington should be up here
talking to you
but you just got us
I want to thank God for this amazing
opportunity
and I think I speak for all of us I want
to thank our families for the amazing
support it is your love and support that
has made this journey possible please
give him a round of applause
and to all of the folks who made this
celebration possible thank you for your
hard work they're the real ones in here
sweating with all of us
but this is a big day we have a lot to
celebrate and it's so much more than the
four names that have been announced
we need to celebrate this moment in
human history
because Artemis 2 is more than a mission
to the Moon and back it's more than a
mission that has to happen before we
send people to the surface of the Moon
it is the next step on the journey that
gets Humanity to Mars yeah you can clap
for that that's good
and this this crew This Crew will never
forget that
now we have a lot of work to do before
we get there and we understand that and
when talking about that work you you may
often hear people say human spaceflight
is a marathon not a Sprint
but we have watched the people that work
so hard to make our mission possible and
I can tell you it is a series of Sprints
that's called a relay race human space
flight is like a relay race and that
baton has been passed generation to
generation and from crew member to crew
member
from the Germany Mercury Germany Apollo
Apollo soyuz Skylab Mir the shuttle
International Space Station commercial
crew and the and now the Artemis
missions
and we understand our role in that and
when we have the privilege of having
that baton we're going to do our best to
run a good race to make you proud
I pray that God will bless this mission
but I also pray that we can continue to
serve as a source of inspiration for
cooperation and peace not just between
nations but in our own Nation thank you
and God bless us all
thank you
thanks Victor awesome words when I uh
what I wanted to highlight for all of
you today is well you know big picture
when I step back there are two reasons
why a Canadian is going to the Moon that
makes me smile when I say that
uh the first one is American leadership
it is not lost on any of us that the
United States could choose to go back to
the Moon by themselves
but America has made a very deliberate
Choice over decades to curate a global
team
and that in my definition is true
leadership a body an entity that seeks
out others who can contribute right
allows them to rise up lifts them up to
make their contributions to bring their
genius that is American leadership and
as a Canadian I am very proud to reflect
that back to you and I am grateful all
Canada is all of Canada is grateful for
that Global mindset and that leadership
so thank you
the second reason is Canada's can do
attitude
for
yeah
for decades now literally thousands upon
thousands of Canadians have risen to
that challenge to bring real value to
the international partnership with
respect to space exploration to bring
real solutions our scientists our
Engineers the Canadian space agency the
Canadian Armed Forces across government
all of our leadership
working together under a vision to take
step by step and all of those have added
up to this moment where a Canadian is
going to the Moon with our International
partnership and it is glorious
so at the end of it all I am left in awe
of being reminded what strong leadership
setting big goals with a passion to
collaborate and a can-do attitude can
achieve and we are going to the Moon
together let's go
thank you uh Victor thank you Jeremy
thank you Reed
it is an honor to be here I also want to
thank our families the Trailblazers our
colleagues and our leadership
my fellow astronauts know that one of
the questions we get all the time is are
you excited and I can tell you
when I think about this Mission that's a
relay race with International Partners
it's also so awesome in and of itself
we are going to launch from Kennedy
Space Center through the work of the
exploration ground systems team
we're going to hear the words go for
launch
on top of the most powerful rocket
NASA's ever made the space launch system
and we're going to ride that rocket for
eight minutes into Earth orbit we're not
going to go to the moon right away
we're going to stay in an amazing High
orbit reaching a peak of tens of
thousands of miles while we test out all
the systems on Orion and even see how it
Maneuvers in space and then if
everything looks good we're heading to
the Moon
it will be a four day Journey going a
quarter of a million miles
continuing to test out every bit of
Orion going around The Far Side of the
Moon heading home
going through the Earth's atmosphere at
over 25
000 miles per hour and splashing down in
the Pacific
so am I excited
absolutely
but my real question is are you excited
I see you
[Applause]
and I asked that because the one thing
I'm most excited about
is that we are going to carry your
excitement your aspirations your dreams
with us on this mission
Artemis 2.
your mission
I think I'm in pretty good hands
um Victor Jeremy Christina thank you
guys for those words absolutely awesome
we're just going to close the crew would
not close without just saying thank you
that is thank you to the NASA Workforce
thank you to our industry Partners thank
you to the Canadian space agency
everyone in Europe that's working for
this we got people in Airbus working our
European service module this is a global
effort Artemis 2 and it's only going to
get larger with Artemis 3 and Beyond as
we get private space flight involved
SpaceX is building our Lander for
Artemis 3. so to the NASA Workforce to
our program managers our Center
directors that are here the amazing
political support that we feel right now
to bring our country together to bring
our entire world together to go explore
to get to Mars and Beyond we say a huge
thank you
uh to the astronauts that are over here
a huge thank you you are our friends you
are our families you're our colleagues
and uh I do want to highlight right now
there are seven folks on the
International Space Station where's Joel
on Joel's International Space Station
orbiting our planet right now
three cosmonauts three Americans and an
emirati from the United Arab Emirates
if any of you over there are looking for
Heroes today go Google these folks
because they're Our Heroes and I
definitely want to call out
our friend Frank Rubio who uh has
already spent six months up there and
Frank is going to spend another six
months due to a uh an issue with the
spacecraft so he'll be up in space for
over an entire year all right that man
is a hero
for sure
but
and then and then Frank Rubio leads me
to Deb Rubio his wife and his four kids
that family those are heroes they are
putting it out there and they're getting
the job done and it is amazing and she
still gives us eggs fresh from her
chickens at her Farm whenever we go over
there I mean it's totally awesome the
Rubio family's amazing family and that
brings the four of us to our families
who are in the audience with us this is
going to be a relay race unlike any
you've ever run and we are so happy to
have you with us thank you
exactly
you got more you want to say Reed
there's three words that we keep saying
in the three words that we keep saying
in this Artemis program we are going and
I want everybody to say it on three one
two three
that was awesome
I gotta say you guys choked me up a
little bit so I appreciate that I want
to thank you all for sharing in this
moment today
thank you to all of our speakers and
esteemed guests and thanks to our crew
Reed Victor Christina and Jeremy as they
get ready to embark on this journey
I'll ask all of my fellow astronauts to
join us back up here come on up everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I love this office and as you can see we
love each other we need a picture
one of our colleagues in space right now
Steve Bowen likes to say human space
flight is the ultimate team sport
when these four fly around the Moon they
won't be doing it alone
they're part of a team a team of
astronauts Engineers
scientists trainers a team of support
working around our country and around
the globe ready day and night
so we'll cheer them on we will help them
carry the incredible weight and it's a
heavy one now laid on their shoulders
because we go together for all Humanity
thank you
together
[Music]
I'm Christina cook I'm the mission
specialist I'm Jeremy Hanson I'm a
mission specialist I'm Victor Glover I'm
the title I'm Reed Wiseman I'm the
commander of the Artemis 2 mission to
the moon to the moon to the Moon
please
[Music]
when I was young I had a poster of the
earthrise picture the famous picture
that was taken on Apollo 8 and the fact
that it was a human behind the lens that
made that picture so profound and
changed how we all thought of our own
home was so amazing to me the Moon is
not just a symbol of thinking about our
place in the universe it's not just a
symbol of exploration it's actually a
beacon for science it's a beacon for
understanding where we came from you
know pushing ourselves to explore is
just core to who we are that's a part of
being a human that's our nature we go
out there and we explore to learn about
where we are why we are understanding
the big questions about our place in the
universe the exploration we're doing is
the first few steps on the path of
getting humans to Mars the Artemis
campaign emissions have set such an
ambitious goal for Humanity that's
inspiring contributions from around the
globe not just one nation is inspired
and moved by this but nations from
around the globe are coming together
when I look at the Artemis 2 crew with
Victor Christina and Jeremy they want to
go do this Mission they are keenly
driven they are humble to a thought it
is so cool to be around them Artemis 2
is a huge Mission but I hope we will
look back and realize that this was one
tiny step in humans on Mars and the
sustained presence
[Music]
Barnes 2 will be NASA's first crude
flight test of the space launch system
rocket and Orion spacecraft around the
Moon to verify today's capabilities for
humans to explore deep space and pave
the way for NASA's long-term human and
scientific presence on the lunar surface
we are ready we are going to the move
for all Humanity we are artists
[Music]